hey there I'm Alicia Malone from
Fandango movie clips and here are five
reasons to get excited for the 40th
annual Toronto International Film
Festival reason one the possible Oscar
contenders TIFF is the perfect place to
kick off that all-important Oscar
campaign and I have my eye on the Danish
girl it's got all the elements in a
reward movie
Oscar pedigree with director Tom Hooper
and star Eddie Redmayne it's based on a
true story with an important emotional
topic which involves a physical
transformation and Eddie Redmayne looks
even better than me with this hair
colour reason to the big premieres the
Toronto Film Festival attracts a lot of
ælis stars with its mix of smaller and
bigger films opening the festival is
demolition a romantic drama directed by
jean-marc vallée who is behind Dallas
buyers club and wild this one stars
Naomi Watts and my future husband Jake
Gyllenhaal also rolling out the red
carpets is Ridley Scott's the Martian
starring Matt Damon and spotlight with
Michael Keaton Mark Ruffalo and Rachel
McAdams we've got two stories hear a
story about degenerate clergy and a
story about a bunch of lawyers turning
child abuse into a cottage industry
which story do you want us to write
because we're writing one reason three
the gangster films TIFF is where we'll
finally get to see Johnny Depp as Whitey
Bulger in Black Mass but I'm really
excited for double Tom Hardy in the very
stylish legend he plays both of the
real-life gangster twins the Kray
brothers and if anyone can pull that
supercro role off it'll be Tom Hardy
reason for the documentaries there's a
great lineup of Doc's at TIFF this year
from he named me Malala about the young
Nobel Peace Prize laureate to Michael
Moore's where will we invade next the
details on that film have been kept
quiet but it's been said this is Moore's
most provocative and hilarious
documentary yet and reason five the
festival favorites with TIFF being held
towards the end of the year they've
curated the best from the previous fests
including I smile back from Sundance
with Sarah Silverman wouldn't be
surprised if she's nominated for that
performance be very quirky the lobster
with Colin Farrell which played to rave
reviews and can
and Sicario by denis villeneuve which
also played in can if you loved
prisoners then you will enjoy this dark
thriller starring Emily Blunt Josh
Brolin and Benicio del Toro
those are our five reasons to be excited
for tips this year but what about yours
let us know in the comments below and
make sure you subscribe to Fandango
movie clips I'm Alisha Malone